good afternoon everybody welcome to this
year's Tanner lectures at at Yale
University hosted by the Whitney
humanities center I'm Gary Tomlinson I'm
the director of the Whitney we're
gathered of course to hear from a coelom
Ben Bay who is a research professor at
the University of the Witwatersrand
in Johannesburg South Africa and more
specifically at the Wits Institute for
social and economic research wiser as it
is known and we're delighted by the way
to have the director of wiser professor
Sarah Nuttall with us also today Sarah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I've known professor in Bembe since we
were colleagues at the University of
Pennsylvania some 25 years ago and is a
huge pleasure for me to welcome him to
this stage today I know we are in for
today tomorrow and Thursday not only an
intellectual feast but something more
since professor and Ben bay has in his
many writings it's not too much to say
recast the terms of post-colonial
analysis and critique this achievement
is particularly marked in his most
recent book but one critique of black
reason where he leads us to understand
blackness not only as a project of the
imagination shaped by half a millennium
of subjugation enslavement exploitation
murder but also as the condition that
all the worlds subaltern people are
subjected to today by the forces of
neoliberal capital but I leave further
introduction of Professor and Ben Bay to
my colleague Michael Denning to me it's
left to outline the schedule of towner
events over the next two days and to say
a few words about the tanaris as an
institution this afternoon we hear the
first of professor in Ben Bay's two
lectures afterwards you're all invited
to a reception here at the Whitney it's
straight down the hall directly behind
you tomorrow again at 5 o'clock
professor and Ben Bay will present his
second lecture and after that there will
be a short question and answer session
and then on Thursday morning finally at
10:30 we reconvene for a discussion
among professor and Bembe professor
Denning and another Yale professor in
Dupont rule at that session there will
be additional opportunity for questions
from the audience as to the Tanner
lectures on human values they were
established by the American scholar
industrialist and philanthropist tobert
Clark Tanner and his wife grace Tanner
for many years a professor at the
University of Utah and a scholar of the
New Testament educated at Harvard and
Stanford Tanner also founded in 1927
early in his adulthood
a jewelry company in Salt Lake City the
company later expanded into broad areas
of human resource consulting and
employee recognition programs they made
trophies and and placards and so on for
25 years of service and things like that
and
that made a whole lot of money and it is
on the base of that corporation that the
Tanner foundation and Overton grace
Tanner's philanthropic efforts are built
these efforts include today the Tanner
lectures at Yale and at a number of
other universities in the United States
Great Britain and beyond the purpose
over at Tanner and visits for the Tanner
lectures is to advance and reflect upon
scholarly and scientific learning
relating to human values in creating the
lectureships
professor Tanner knowingly left his
purview very broad he wrote I see these
lectures simply as a search for a better
understanding of human behavior and
human values this understanding may be
pursued for its own intrinsic worth but
it may also eventually have practical
consequences for the quality of personal
and social life unquote appointment as a
Tanner lecturer is a recognition of
uncommon achievement on outstanding
abilities in the area of human values
and studies and we are honored to add
professor and Bembe to the list of
distinguished scholars and humanists
whom Yale has so recognized at Yale the
Tanner lectures are selected by the
president in consultation with the
director and executive committee of the
Whitney humanities Center so were also
indebted to Yale president Peter Salovey
who will be here tomorrow night for his
assistance in bringing today's speaker
to us now it's my pleasure to welcome to
the podium
Michael Denning William our keen and
junior professor of American Studies and
English to introduce our speaker
[Applause]
thank you Gary it's a great pleasure to
welcome a shilling them.they back to
Yale to deliver the Tanner lecture
borders in the age of networks I won't
repeat that he's a research professor
with spotters Ron oh just say I last
introduced a shield to a Yale audience
in 2007 and in the decades since he has
published three major books and I
thought start with those rather than
going way back the first in 2010 was
sortie de la grenouille an allusion to
phantoms call to shake off the great
mantle of night essai sur la freak de
colonies a si undie colonized Africa not
yet translated into English it opens
with an extraordinarily powerful
autobiographical narrative of a country
and three cities first and please excuse
my halting translations I hope they're
accurate born in the shadow of a country
without a proper name Cameroon the name
given by Portuguese seaman marveling at
the abundance of shrimp tomorrow in the
river and born in the shadow of and I
quote the first age of post colonialism
in childhood and adolescence and in the
shadow of songs of lamentation for the
disavowed martyrs of the anti-colonial
struggle and the schoolroom anthems of
the post-colonial nation and potentate
then as when intellectuals and I quote
since the time of fennel says there and
sang gore having taken his masters at
the University of Yahoo day he left for
Paris where he took his doctorate at the
Sorbonne and New York where he taught at
Columbia and where I won't summarize his
luminous pages on what those two cities
meant to
he became a historian not only of the
resistance in Cameroon editing a
collection of the writings of the marbet
martyred Rubin oom the Oba and
publishing in 1996 the birth of the
resistance in South Cameroon but of the
surpluses of post-colonial Africa and he
forged the remarkable dialectic of
historical reflection and critical
theory that has come to characterize his
style in first on the post colony
translated into English tin 2000 and
translated into English in 2001 but then
in the last year of the 20th century as
he puts it he arrived in South Africa in
the shadow and I'm quoting here again
the Maelstrom in the shadow of the
Maelstrom that was apartheid
it's statues still standing its streets
not yet renamed in a city Johannesburg
the most modern most powerful and most
racially mixed of African metropolis
--is a new frontier of the continent
where one finds almost all the
nationalities of the world a migrant to
Johannesburg it is from Johannesburg
that a shield man Bembe has over the
last two decades reimagined our world in
his account of Africa's attempt to shake
off the great mantle of night in his
extraordinary 2013 book critique of
black reason which has just been
translated into English a philosophical
history of the invention of black reason
the Western consciousness of Africa and
blackness in the shadow of the slave
trade and colonialism of the reversal of
that black reason into the black reason
that is the polyglot internationalism of
the modern black imaginary in figures
from Garvey and Dubois to fennel and
Mandela
and finally to the becoming
lack of the world and most recently in
the 2016 book the politics of enmity a
chapter of which which has been recently
translated in radical philosophy a
reflection on a world dominated by the
desire for an enemy a desire for
apartheid a desire for separation and
exclusion and walls and the new forms of
nano racism and hydraulic racism that
that world has shaved throughout all his
work he has been haunted by death and
corpses necro politics has been one of
his most influential essays and death
stretches across his work from the
cemeteries in Cameroon to the amazing
essay on Mandela's mortality written
together with Sara knodel however
recalling the songs of lamentation of
his grandmother for the son assassinated
in the resistance
he writes that these songs served to
accompany his shadow and to open for him
away to a possible repose in
compensation for the unspeakable
injustice the victim experienced after
his demise in a similar way a Sheila
man-beasts writings accompany the
shadows of the Dead and undead of our
world and open a way to a possible
repose and in common as he calls it
beyond the unspeakable and justices of a
society of M natee please join me in
welcoming a coelom Ben V for the first
of his two Tanner lectures the new
global mobility regime
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I would like to thank Gary and the
University for a very gracious
invitation as gary said we're both
colleagues with many years ago he said
25 years and suddenly realized that tom
has been passing rather quickly but as
you can testify Gary looks always looks
very young both physically and in his
mind the Gary was and has been all along
his work has been a great inspiration
for a lot of us I would also like to
extend my gratitude to Michael
I like Michael very very much I know he
likes me too
as well you could see with his
introduction and I'm very glad my wife
sir nothing is here perhaps more than
any other hours is is an epoch of
fantasies when such fantasy is that of
total security Oh perfectly controlled
or tightened borders the dream of
impenetrable and insurmountable limits
which is the same thing as the dream of
a domain without an outside domain whose
walls cannot be broken through and whose
boundaries can never be crossed if only
because they are continuously redrawn
displaced and
and pushed back so as the twin logics of
order and security on the one hand and
freedom and movement on the other
confront one another
borders almost everywhere
increasingly found in unexpected places
in the not-so-distant past borders have
always been generative of new modes of
power and a new political reason such
was the case in 1884 1885 when meeting
in Berlin for what was then known as the
Congo conference 14 European powers
divided Africa among them for the
purpose of colonization this they did by
coming out the entire continent and by
superimposing all pre-existing political
entities and cultures a hotspot of
geometric boundaries that divided it
into 50 aberrant countries as clearly
pointed out in the general acts of the
conference this was all a quote in the
name of free trade and civilization as
article 2 of that general act of the
conference specifies a quote again all
flags without distinction of nationality
shall have free access to the whole of
the coastline of the territories above
enumerated in rated in article 1 - the
rivers they're running into the sea -
all the waters of the Congo and its
effluence including the links and to all
the ports situated on the banks of
waters as well as to all the canals
which may in future be constructed with
intent to unite the water courses or
lakes within the entire area of the
territories described in article one and
of course the same article one starts
with the following statement quote again
the trade of all nations shall enjoy
complete freedom follows
geographical specification which is at
the same time a naming of a large
boundary and the claiming of a huge
chunk of territory called the basin of
the cool and so it goes a new mode of
power a new political reason but even
more crucially a claim made in relation
to an assemblage of territories
territories made of rivers of mountains
ridges and watersheds lakes maritime
zones lines purlins and latitudes points
of demarkation and assemblage of
territories power is seeking to take
possession of so at the beginning or at
least in our colonial experience the
resident of the border is to attend to
the problem of the distribution of the
earth how much the earth of land be
distributed to whom does the earth
belong who can lay what type of claim to
what part of it to whom should be
allotted what share who determines its
distribution or partition in its
colonial roots geopolitics is about the
multiple
tribution of populations not only human
on the body of the earth it is about the
modes of occupation and the distribution
of the earth and the manner in which
these modes affect the vital forces of
our kinds of beings human and non-human
yesterday borders used to manifest
themselves in two major ways first asked
tangible physical features usually
located at the edge of state territory
and second as sites where discretionary
sovereign decisions were made in
relation to whether to permit or to
exclude what whom under what terms
nowadays they are ever more mobile
complex differentiated dispersed and
fertilized just as they remain contested
as more and more people find themselves
on the move new laws regulations
bureaucracies and procedures are
produced in a renewed attempt at
controlling and regulating the movements
through and across the border escapes of
our world and in an effort at setting
the terms under which foreign bodies
might enter reside work settle and
perhaps integrate in countries other
than they own migration policy which is
mostly about the control of human
mobility is once again seen as a key
index of sovereignty in a world of flows
risks and threats furthermore border
work work of instituting enacting
boundaries understood mostly as powers
highly and even
imperfect and yet incessant labour to
contain mobility border work
is evermore incorporated into everyday
ways of life it is enhanced by numerous
security schemes and technologies
supposedly configured to operate
objectively schemes objectively that is
without prejudice or discrimination such
security technologies are listed in
order is increasingly an automated
calculation of threats the key feature
of our times they are configured in such
a way as to track and veil and sort that
which is hidden that which must be
detected and inspected that which is out
of place or unauthorized concealed
identities apparent movements categories
of potential enemies actual human bodies
in this age of generalized suspicion
indeed this is also an epoch when the
human body or more precisely that body
that is not mine RIA merges as
potentially dangerous and meshed as it
is with various figures of threat and
insecurity threat to cultural identity
threat to the welfare state threat to
public order and even an exist ensel
threat to our way of life and our way of
being according to the new world
security rationale although everybody is
potentially dangerous until proven
otherwise some categories of bodies and
persons carry almost by definition more
risks than others even at the most
vulnerable state they fundamentally
endanger our lives as such they must be
the object of renewed profiling
classification
in our solution or even eliminated in
line with a long history in modernity
that ties together the targeting
quarantining restriction and even
extermination of populations that have
been marked as abnormal or have been
profoundly dishonored the obsession with
the borders of the human body in
particular the borders of that body that
is not mine
has in turn unleashed a renewed
algorithmic production of its nude image
by fully body scanners and his
examination screens at a time when
security is equated with visibility and
concealment with threat what the body
looks like what its parts are what are
its shapes and forms what objects is it
concealing and what others shouldn't it
these are questions the new matrix of
threat and risk is forcing us to ask
with urgency so over the last 15 years a
huge amount of empirical work has been
done in relation to both borders and
migration and it is not my intention to
rehearse it here the wealth of data
already accumulated has helped sharpen
our understanding of mobility and of
borders of capture immobility and flight
it has also highlighted the extent to
which various processes are unfolding
simultaneously the freeing of internal
mobility for some and the hardening of
external boundaries for others
phenomenon such as the specialization of
state sovereignty the securitization of
migration
the merging of criminal justice and
immigration policy the extraterritorial
ization of certain practices related to
migration management these and other
processes have been the object of
extensive and careful descriptions
drawing from this material it seems to
me it's now possible to rethink what is
at stake when the biopolitics of
mobility intersects with the geopolitics
of our times the kind of political
reason that is produced at this
intersection in other words what is it
that contemporary migratory struggles
tell us about the border regimes of our
times and the processes of control and
capture of bodies capture of motion
capture of speed and ultimately capture
of life itself
in the current convulsion these are some
of the questions I would like to examine
during these lectures I will be using x
interchangeably such terms as borders
migration mobility movement these are
obviously technical concepts borders are
at the front line of present-day
geopolitics they are also the sites
where sovereignty is the most subject to
reanimation to be sure the
long-established concept of territorial
physical or political boundary of a
state still has relevance in a world in
which lines and claims and compartments
have not entirely disappeared the lines
that continue to separate us are still
there but boundaries or borders and no
longer conceived merely as wars offenses
even when they manifest themselves as
tangible physical features located at
the edge of state territory they are
increasingly understood as a contingent
assemblage of of social practices
subject to to change they are
increasingly understood as relational
arrangements of bodies in spaces and not
only as as containers in fact as argued
by many the discretionary sovereign
decisions that are taken at borders
ultimately the result of various
interactions between border guards
detection devices sniffer dogs humans
nonhumans bordering actions or practices
in that sense represent a provisional
stabilization of various forces and
devices forces with competing
understandings of threat forces whose
function is to enact or perform security
in the [ __ ] face of cunning and
supposedly merciless enemy others and so
a border in this sense is the result of
how mobility control regime's use
difference to constitute different
spatial practices so the Porter I'm
trying to make is that as a matter of
fact there is no homogenizing border
logic there isn't difference and
territoriality are always practiced in
fractured and passionless at least there
is one thing we draw from the voluminous
amount of research
I was referring to this having been seen
and taken together these terms borders
mobility movement and so on these terms
all mean one thing the multiple
distributions of human populations on
the body of the earth
that's how understand these terms they
all refer to the same thing the
monitoring of the movements of
populations that secret on the surface
of the earth or that happened to settle
somewhere for various reasons but in my
understanding what is ultimately at
stake in the current planetary politics
of mobility is the drawing of the new
limits of the earth in this context the
main function of borders is precisely to
push outside to throw outside that body
that is not mine
or to put it in heidegger's terms the
wrong people with the wrong blood as
heidecker's expression in this sense the
border has the status of law to be sure
border does not only exclude or separate
can also connect but overall the border
is in the last instance always conceived
in its disjunctive use in always refers
in the last instance to those
populations coming from the outside and
in relation to which it must act as a
filter or which it actually threatens
so I start from the assumption that any
form of mobility finds its limit at the
border the border is that which
interrupts movement emotion and in
modernity border control has played two
decisive functions has been key device
in the planetary management of
populations it has also been a key
vector for the configuration of various
degrees of subjecthood flow and
distribution of bodies the constitution
of subjects with our rights and a
preeminent sight for the execution of
state violence the limit where life
matters the most
so the questions I'm asking the
following toward new existences new
borders bear witness in our contemporary
world why in the confrontation with
borders why do so many people why are
they compelled towards experimenting at
the limits of the livable this way of
framing the issue is markedly different
from the three approaches that have of
late dominated debates on mobility in
the edge of borders and networks of the
various strands that have of late
dominated such debates three in
particular should be highlighted a first
trend centered around the concept of
precarity or precarious lives has sought
to delineate the interconnections
between neural work and welfare regimes
immigration controls and exploitation or
hyper exploitation of international
migrant labor today indeed more than at
of a moment of our recent history
migrants are centrally implicated in
highly precarious work experiences at
the bottom end of labor markets
literally in western capitalist
countries but also in various parts of
the global south as the case in South
Africa as the case in Gulf countries so
forth and soon the concept of precarity
has been mobilized in an effort to
describe those life world's epitomized
by migrant existence an existence that
is inflected with uncertainty and
instability it is a concept that has
been understood both as a descriptor and
as a condition condition let me repeat
which itself is a consequence of
neoliberal globalization and rate
transformations in the world of work and
precarity in this instance has been used
as a kid planetary framework for new
forms of workplace exploitation the idea
that the life of the migrant at the
bottom end of the labor leader ladder is
the metaphor of precarious life this
idea refers to something more than a
position in the labor market precarity
has also been understood as something
intertwined with other areas of life
something almost it is tension which
speaks to the inability to predict one
phase once one's fate or to enjoy the
degree of stability on which to build
social relations and feelings of
affection precarity has finally been
understood as a condition of structural
insecurity as a consequence of
differential exposure to violence and
suffering that emanates from
socio-political context that's the first
way in which the question of mobility
borders
violence has been dealt with through the
lens of this concept of recurrent a
second strand of debates on migration
has focused on emerging geographies of
detention imprisonment and confinement
in other words the castle landscapes of
our world the idea here is that a
migrant body on the move in a way that
is not authorised is almost by
definition likely to end up in one form
or another of a prison to be detained
confined deported is part of the options
he or she permanently faces the driving
concept in this case has been that of
categorical vulnerability indeed during
2009 alone in the u.s. approximately
380,000 people spent time in the vast
and continues expanding migrant
detention system according to detention
watch network this system consistent
then of approximately 350 facilities
operating at an annual cost of more than
1.7 billion u.s. dollars in other
countries such as the UK the use of
migrant detention in the form of Asylum
screening units has expanded across the
European Union detention facilities have
similarly proliferated and now number in
the hundreds
while Australia has intensified
detention practices on an offshore in
short the world has witnessed a
significant expansion of landscapes of
detention over the last decade so has
been the growth of detention
choose along transnational routes
travelled by migrants in the journeys
through northern Africa Eastern Europe
Indonesia and Central America
simultaneously detention and deportation
have become more than ever
interlocked industries in this context
an important strand of Studies on
borders and mobility has been
preoccupied with the extent to which the
categorical vulnerability to which
migrants and undocumented people are
subjected to what extent is this
category legally produced then there is
a third strand which has focused on the
warehousing of refugees and asylum
seekers here too the number of people in
the world fleeing conditions of war
violence disasters economic distress and
environmental collapse has been swelling
in 2014 the number of forcibly displaced
people in the world surpassed the record
number of people displaced in the
aftermath of the Second World War I
think the latest figures we have had
last year
flag see we are told that there are 65
million people 65 million refugees in
search of asylum in a world as we speak
whatever from whatever angle one
examines it the border therefore remains
bio political space and in a number of
instances border crossing has become a
matter of life and death in such a
context humanitarian border works
goal is not to abolish border controls
or to contest the border as a space of
exercise of sovereign power but to turn
it into a space both of risk you and of
provision of basic emergency came the
rescaling and outsourcing of borders is
not only happening inland it is also
happening offshore especially on deserts
and islands where high measures of
inclusion aim at shutting down paths to
asylum but containing people trying to
reach sovereign territories in M smaller
and more remote locations such is
notably the case with Europe Southern
peripheries in particular the to Spanish
and claves
of Ceuta and Melilla in Malaya following
the arrival of the first group of
African migrants Spain built a three
metre high fence 12 kilometres square in
in Malaya which is a 12 kilometer square
and cleave which is located in fact in
in northeastern Morocco which has been
under Spanish sovereignty since the late
15th century furious later the EU
finance the construction of a six metre
high three-tier fence equipped with
manned control posts infrared cameras
acoustic sensors and motion detectors
the EU also put pressure on Miroku to
control its side of the border in
response Morocco initiated regular
military cleanup operations most of
which consisted in putting migrants in
tracks take
them to the city of Susa further down
south near the border with Algeria and
dumping them there or in the desert the
key component of the strategy of
outsourcing European border control has
expanded outwardly
with the assistance of third countries
at the same time as internal border
control is strengthened through
surveillance agencies increased rates of
deportation and the proliferation of
internment centers as far as outsourcing
is concerned the Moroccan government has
been building its own barbed wire fence
and fence partially financed by the EU
subsidies and located to Spain for
border control the same thing is
happening as we speak
throughout the Sahara Desert in places
such as Michel Libya of course Burkina
Faso and along the coast of Senegal
typical of the distinctly neoliberal
articulation between securitisation and
free-market internationalism the same
countries that are determined to secure
their borders actively engaged in the
construction of free trade partnerships
with the very same neighbors from whom
they seek to protect themselves which
raises of course the question of
selective permeability in other words of
whose interest the opening or closing of
border service I could go on on the case
of these two and claves and Islands or
talk with more about the desert but the
point I really want to make is not the
three strands
I have evoked all point towards one
thing
they point towards the fact that are
working and rescaling of borders is in
the making and it is in the making at a
planetary level globally it is in the
making as a result of the emergence of a
new mobility regime one which is
planetary in scale and I would now like
to say a few words about these new
mobility regime I have gone to some
length describing the ways in which
Islands enter into these new calculus of
mobility
I also alluded to the extent to which
deserts are implicated in the same
process I would not like to focus on
what we should more broadly call the
liquid frontier because the liquid
frontier is at the vanguard of the
redefinition of sovereignty in the
contemporary world in order to
understand the liquid from TM and how
its reorganizes sovereignty and
contributes to the making of a new
global mobility regime an excursion
through harsh myths normals of the earth
is necessary if only because for Schmitt
the fundamental distinction on which
geopolitics has been predicated
geopolitics in the sense of the
distribution of the earth and the
distribution of the earth which are
equated with mobility and borders at the
beginning evenly because for him
geopolitics has been predicated on a
binary division between a solid land
where territories can
be clearly demarcated and where order
may be imposed and the sea so land on
the one hand the sea on the other where
borders according to Schmidt
in any case can be neither traced no
held and we're in smitten imaginary
freedom reigns absolute that's how he
understand see the sea of course this is
an idealization of the sea sea as an
empty almost abstract and frictionless
geometric space open to navigation
question of navigation which we found to
when I was referring to the carving of
of Africa during the Berlin conference
so this idealization of course it has
been predict in fact as we not now
realize oceans hardly cover space evenly
oceans in fact a fabric that is full of
holes it is stitched together out of
pieces the sea is if we want a tangle of
strings that we know now
Schmidt might not have known about this
but at least now we have the advantage
of knowing no better than he did but the
liquid territory of the sea nevertheless
offers a number of particularities first
because water covers over 70% of the
surface area of a planet many frontiers
in the world today are located in the
sea first first Pole
and the see is what we can can get in
terms of the idea of an absolute
boundary or boundaries are relative but
even where to imagine if only for a
second what an absolute boundary might
look like we have to look north on land
but on the sea
it is the only absolute boundary because
it alone blocks the the continuous
expansion of other people you know known
the legend Guattari believe that the
desert does that better than the sea but
these are discussions we can explore
later so the sea does that and and yet
it can be domesticated to bring people
into contact it a neighbor's circulation
while adding friction to movement while
adding friction to life
the other interesting thing with a sea a
laydown all of these and I would draw
the conclusion at the end and you see
where I'm going
the third interesting thing with the sea
according to Schmidt is that of course
it is turned by currency and waves and
by being stirred by currents and waves
it seems to erase any trace including
traces of the past or to relegate and
contain them and it's very bottom and
because of these apparent permanent
erasure of our traces the sea seems to
maintain everything in a kind of
permanent present according to Smith
furthermore still with Schmidt part of
what characterizes this vast expanse is
the lack of stable habitation on its
surface I mean this was probably before
the all digging all extraction which
which day allows for I mean in
habitations on the surface but we are
not yet there with Schmidt he's still
writing at the time when this doesn't
seem at all possible and because of this
lack of stable habitation a quote him
events at C occur mostly outside of the
public gaze endless remain unaccounted
for its lack of accountability as
characteristic feature of what happens
at sea even more importantly throughout
modernity maritime governance has always
oscillated between two pools on the one
hand the desire to divide up the waters
of the earth
in a way that would mirror the carving
up of territorial boundaries on land and
on the other hand the vision of the
ocean has opened to free navigation the
so-called free seas Hugo gracias wrote
about in his chignon and text Marilee
Barry
whatever the case
Smith was wrong we've been wrong he
wasn't wrong he got stuck let's put
let's put it like that with his
distinction with his Lancie binary
what has happened of late is that the
new modes of regulation of human
mobility have tried to go beyond these
Lancie binary by being attuned more than
ever before to the vertical dimensions
of marathon spaces and in so doing we
are nowadays able to decipher a much
more complex form of governance than the
simple opposition between territorial
control and DT literalized flows what I
mean by this is that in the new regimes
of mobility many have come to the
realization that in fact territorial
control can go hand in hand with details
of realized flows
what we have today therefore is a far
more complex jurisdictional regime and
more of government governs in which the
rights and obligations that compose
modern state sovereignty on the land
decoupled from each other and applied to
a variety crease depending on a spatial
extent in this big issue in question
this is what Saskia Sassen calls and
bundled sovereignty in this partial
sovereignty regime intersect with ever
shifting lines of control in which
routes and traffic have become key what
does it mean means that in the making of
the new regime of mobility motion has
been put at the center and if we want to
control the migration of people what you
have to follow as carefully as possible
and trace is the movement of people
along routes and intersections along
their journeys so sovereignty and
governance attempt now to be exercised
on routes and traffic to follow those
routes to polish them while policing in
the same way high seas are policed
so 70 in this case has to do with the
negotiation of the inextricable
articulation between freedom and control
which is characteristic need of forms of
mobility learners in neo liberal
societies and these sets of lines there
are some simply coexist in fact the
carving up of partial sovereignty
regimes is the very basis for governance
in motion I have used the C to show the
extent to which it has become a
laboratory in which contemporary modes
of mobility control have been devised
experimented with which are now being
brought to bear on the land so what used
to be done exclusively at sea is now
done on land on the land as at sea
border functions on the land have been
decoupled from the limits of the
temporal border and are becoming
increasingly dispersed and mobile able
to follow ever shifting homes that's
what is the kernel of the new mobility
regime now one of the most significant
transformations in terms of geopolitics
of mobility is without that the blurring
of inside-outside and the extent to
which borders have been externalized and
the border has become a transnational
assemblage number of authors speak in
this regard about the emergence of a
territorial extended increasingly
informal and itinerant bordering some
large of institutions state authorities
policies that react to
and turbulent migratory movements at the
same time the outsourcing offshoring and
extractive realization of border work
has led to a special illegal stretching
of the domains of migration control and
a redefinition of the jurisdictions and
authorities traditionally associated
with border management we see it in
places such as Senegal Mauritania Niger
Burkina Faso Morocco Algeria Libya where
the the shifting performance of
sovereignty entails the ability for the
security forces of European countries to
act in tandem with forces of these third
States in an attempt at cutting of the
roots of migration of course all of this
raises all kinds of dilemmas these forms
of mobile sovereignty legal and
institutional foundations for such
programs remains unclear
particularly with the near permanent
business operational border control
policy for forces involved in in other
states now let me move on and come back
to the body question of the body with
which I started
I indicated that the rescaling of
borders has entailed a global expansion
of security infrastructure ranging from
physical and virtual wars to the
deployment of drones and military
hardware to monitor and secure space I
argued that novel migration regime is
emerging which requires as I tried to
show through the reference to the sea
which requires a nonlinear understanding
of territory I also argued that the
insight can now be outside the sea on
land and the land on sea and what we
used to take as clothes can be far away
and vice versa all of this geometry is
fast changing and it's changing as a
consequence old models of sovereignty
understood at an earlier period as
control of people taxis and discrete
territories what I would like to add now
let's do with the extent to which in a
world of technology enabled flows
sovereignty over discrete territories
has become almost by definition
incomplete many governments especially
in the North have understood that in
order to govern the movement of people
across borders it is absolutely crucial
to first classify them today one of the
most efficient way to achieve such a
goal is through the harvesting and
strategic use of electronic personal
data
the purpose of classification is to
bring back bodies into a zone of
calculation and manageability this is
the reason why in the new regime of
human mobility I'm referring to
bordering practices have become
digitized through the automation of data
collection and data analysis so what is
being collected genetic information
stored in electronic form in searchable
bases physiological features unique to
individuals such as fingerprints
patterns of the iris and the retina
veins of the hand genomic features such
as voice patterns are transformed via
algorithms to produce so-called
templates these templates in turn are
stored in centralized databases that are
accessed when whenever necessary and
templates are when they are not stored
centrally they put on a chip inserted
into all kinds of documents such as
passport and identicals so in this
context to to classify consists in
converging the data from integrated
bases with biometric identifiers such as
those who have have mentioned and
classification in this instance relies
obviously on a series of dividing
practices in which the the subject is
broken up into calculable risk factors
in other words to classify
which is a very old exercise but to
classify today is to categorize
populations into degrees of riskiness
and classification mostly has to do with
a pre-emptive fixing of identities so
thanks to the biometric turn governments
are embedding the regulatory functions
in various networks of global flows with
the help of digital technologies so that
sovereignty properties can travel with
the flows so two old models of world
model based on the actual physical
control of discrete territories they are
drafting a new model of mobile and
flowing sovereignty in this new models
linear border functions are dislocated
and pushed both adword into as I said
other states territories and inur'd
into national societies now this new
border regime moving towards the end now
has produced several significant spatial
outcomes borders have become more mobile
but more importantly borders have become
portable this opening the entire space
of the globe to potential bordering
processes what I mean by that is that
borders have no limits no longer they
are no longer limits to bordering
processes
there has been an increase in bordering
instances as people can now encounter
borders in various forms in a multitude
of locales within their daily lives
the nature of an individual's encounter
with borders has also changed since this
is often mediated by diverse digital
devices and managed more and more by
travel actors so border control has
become more individualized more
molecular almost similar as digitization
allows surveillance to zero in on the
smaller spaces such as the body and
continuously monitor the body the
question is following why is it that
border security practices have taken
such a keen interest in the connection
between the human body and identity as a
means of achieving detailed control of a
movement
this is the case because human body is
seen as an indisputable anchor to which
data can be safely secured as a result
we are witnessing a gradually extending
entertainment of individual physical
characteristics with information systems
the process that has served to deepen
faith in data as a means of risk
management and faith in the body as a
source of absolute identification here
is that the body remains the truth of
the individual if we want to know who
you are
we better open your body so digital
devices work they are doing is similar
to work of dissection this worries a
stake in the extension of rhetoric
border into multiple organs of social
life in particular into the human body
the most efficient way to regulate
mobile bodies is to turn them into
portable bodies let me conclude the
argument I wanted to make tonight was
pretty straightforward the function of
the border of any border is to
simultaneously divide and define and in
so doing to generate new sets of
relationships between the social special
entities and the actual bodies they
bring into existence borders do not
simply enclose they also provide an
instrument to gain access to or by
access to and evenly geographically
distributed resources as I will show
tomorrow
the tension between mobility and
mobility is itself intrinsic to the
workings of global capital I was
particularly interested in the question
of the body at the border and the
borders of the body
especially that body that is not mine
most of the bodies in motion in our
contemporary world the multiplicity of
bodies attempting to break through the
wall are engaged in an old struggle thus
far to sustain life and the catastrophic
conditions rendered superfluous
by the volatile forces and flows of
capital they are desperately trying to
escape places that have been rendered
and inhabitable
catastrophic conditions should be
defined as those under which each life
and every breath suddenly acquires an
utmost value code as they are in the
Nexus of vulnerability and emergency
what a body is and other body might
become find the limit precisely at that
border of vulnerability and emergency
thank you very much for your attention
[Applause]
[Music]